WEIGHT LISTING.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
SO I FEEL LIKE MAYBE ONLY ONE
OF US IN THIS GROUP MIGHT
ACTUALLY KNOW THIS, BUT THE
MESSAGE BOARDS AT
bodybuilding.com ARE AS STRANGE
AS THEY ARE BROAD.
COMEDIANS, WE WILL GIVE YOU THE
TITLES OF TWO bodybuilding.com
MESSAGE BOARD THREADS AND YOU
HAVE TO GUESS WHICH ONE IS REAL.
SO HERE'S THE FIRST ONE:
HOW CAN I CONTACT A
HONEST-TO-GOD NINJA?
OR: HAD A WEIRD DREAM ABOUT
GEORGE COSTANZA LAST NIGHT.
SERIOUS.
KURT.
>> HAD A WEIRD DREAM ABOUT
GEORGE COSTANZA LAST NIGHT.
>> I BELIEVE THAT IS THE CORRECT
ANSWER: HAD A WEIRD DREAM ABOUT
GEORGE COSTANZA LAST NIGHT.
(LAUGHTER)
LET ME JUST READ YOU A PASSAGE.
GEORGE IS NOW MAD AS (BLEEP) AND
HE GOT HIS HANDS ON ME AND I TRY
TO PUSH HIM AWAY, BUT I CAN'T,
DUDE IS LIKE HULK STRONG.
HE PUSHES ME, PRETTY MUCH LIFTS
ME UP AND THROWS ME ON THE
TABLE.
I'M SURPRISED AS (BLEEP) BY HIS
HUGE POWER.
>> "WHAT IS THE DEAL WITH ANAL
SEX?"
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: WHAT IS THE DEAL WITH
IT?
>> I LOVE THE IDEA THAT SEINFELD
COMES IN AND SEES THIS.
OH, I CAN MAKE SOME
OBSERVATIONAL HUMOR ABOUT THIS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BELIEVE
WHAT'S HAPPENED, JERRY!
(SCREAMS)
(BLEEP)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: JERICHO--
ALL RIGHT, KURT GOT POINTS FOR
THAT.
NOW, I'LL GIVE CHRIS 100 POINTS
FOR JERICHO KRAMER.
NEXT ONE, NEXT ONE: MY FARTS
ARE LITERALLY OUT OF CONTROL,
BRAHS, DEAD SERIOUS.
OR: WHAT KIND OF FISH WOULD BE
CLOSEST IN TEXTURE TO MERMAID
MEAT?
JERICHO.
>> I'M GOING TO SAY WHAT KIND OF
FISH WOULD BE CLOSEST IN TEXTURE
TO MERMAID MEAT.
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
THE CORRECT ANSWER IS:
MY FARTS ARE LITERALLY
OUT OF CONTROL, BRAHS.
DEAD SERIOUS.
IT'S THE EGG WHITES, BRAH.
SERIOUSLY, THEY MAKE MINE SMELL
LIKE SULFUR AND GENOCIDE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> I LIKE THAT THEY ARE
CONSTANTLY REMINDING EVERYONE
THAT THEY'RE SERIOUS.
LIKE THERE'S NOTHING FUNNY
OR INTERESTING ABOUT THIS.
LIKE, NO, SERIOUS, BRAH.
>> OR LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION,
IS IT MY FARTS ARE LITERALLY OUT
OF CONTROL, BRAHS, DEAD SENIORS.
HIS FARTS ARE SO BAD THEY
ACTUALLY KILLED OLD PEOPLE.
>> Chris: OLD PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO--
>> MY FARTS OUT OF CONTROL, DEAD
SENIORS EVERYWHERE.
IF YOU WANT GENOCIDE, I'M GOING
TO GIVE THEM TO YOU, TO THE DEAD
SENIORS.
>> Chris: OH, NO, HE'S COMING
THIS WAY!
NEXT ONE.
"PENIS DOES NOT FIT."
AND THEN THAT'S IT.
PENIS DOES NOT FIT.
OR THE WONDER YE ARS FINALLY
COMING TO DVD.
KURT.
>> PENIS DOES NOT FIT.
JUST BECAUSE A MAN CAN DREAM.
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT.
PENIS DOES NOT FIT!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
AND THE WONDER YEARS FINALLY
COMING TO DVD.
♪ WHAT WOULD YOU DO
IF MY PENIS WAS BIG? ♪
>> WHO SINGS THAT SONG?
>> Chris: JOE COCKER.
POINTS!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
JERICHO, POINTS.